[Music]
crowds treated to a show of the
country's military personnel as hundreds
of soldiers marched their way across Red
Square
[Music]
and an impressive display of loyalty as
troops saluted their generals
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you well the end of President
Putin's speech greeted by chanting under
gunfire salute before the parade
continued and despite a scaled back
event due to recent security concerns
we're told the country's military might
and Hardware was on display including
surface-to-air missiles and tanks
nuclear weapons as well
there was also a moment's silence to
represent
um respect for those who had perished
back in the second world war let's take
a look a listen to what President Putin
had to say in a short but some would say
rousing speech she reinforces special
military operation in Ukraine and
claimed the real war is being waged
against the Kremlin
military operation I congratulate you on
on this Victory Day
it's the celebration
to honor our fathers and grandfathers
who fought for their motherland
through
sacrifice and heroic acts they saved the
world from Nazism
and today the world is on the cast again
and today we have a real war waged
against us we believe that any ideology
of Supremacy is
is not acceptable to us however the
Western Elites and globalists are
insisting on their exceptional
character and their provoking
conflicts
they are encouraging versophobia and
nationalism they are destroying family
Traditional Values that make a person
the person they have forgotten who
destroyed that evil who defended
who liberated the people of Europe we
see that a number of country
they are
trying to delete the memory of real
heroes